more changes could be in the works for
downtown las vegas documents showing the
city planning commission looking at
possibly expanding the arts district as
it stands right now the area makes up
about 84 acres that proposal shows that
could grow as you can see by 47 acres
adding 56 percent to the district
madison kimbrough joining us from
downtown with more on what it could mean
for those in the area hi madison
yes positive reactions from all around
from two businesses we spoke to to
several patrons across the area who say
this is great news for this booming area
it's just a vibe down here it's
something that you can't find anything
else i think in town tonya diaz
describing her experience in the arts
district as a possible expansion could
be in the works a topic of discussion at
tuesday's planning commission meeting i
think if they expand and add more things
it would just attract more people and
someone like me who lives here i'd come
here even like more often and tonya
isn't alone as business owner jason
taylor of nevada brew works located on
main street says it was only a matter of
time i think expanding the boundaries is
something that the city of las vegas
should have considered a long time ago
also mentioning that he hopes the
expansion leads to better lighting along
with a safer path for those walking
throughout the evening i think the goal
really should be to have it continue all
the way down at least to the strat
and sort of make it more of like an
urban and a comfortable walkway area and
over at the redcat vintage clothing
store owner derek campbell says he knows
some of his art gallery friends aren't
too happy about the proposal but he
feels like the possible expansion comes
with the territory as the success of
this neighborhood has
risen so of the rents and now a lot of
the artists and the galleries can't
afford to stay in the neighborhood it's
hard for artists and galleries for sure
but it's it's it is what it is because
art is cool and those areas are usually
cool which brings in people we're all
going to benefit from it i believe you
know so we're excited
and in addition to a possible expansion
just last month the city announced plans
to build a parking garage in the next
two years to keep up with the demand of
this growing district reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now